aber ich finde es eigentlich locker
gründlich vor allem nicht teuer und das
wichtigste das ist gesund und natürlich
vor allem nicht teuer hey was geht ab
märz willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
die ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut
ja heute wird einer neuen 24 stunden
talent einziger unterschied wir fangen
heute zum ersten mal abends an der
anderen stelle das habe ich entweder
morgens oder mittags begonnen
ich habe abends noch nicht so wirklich
aber irgendwann ist immer das erste mal
nach krass also diese airports hatte
jetzt nicht mehr drin weil ich zeigen
wollte dass ich jetzt airports haben die
hatte ich nur noch drin weil man gar
nicht merkt dass man die drin hat also
ich wollte mich jetzt gerade im spiegel
film und hab das dann halt gesehen die
sind aber echt gut an so kann man nur
empfehlen eher leute auf jeden fall war
ich gerade eben einkaufen und ich habe
ordentlich was eingekauft ich muss sagen
ich gehe stark davon aus die challenge
heute wird im vergleich zu online
spielen ist wirklich sehr sehr günstig
was ja schon mal gut ist kurzem habe ich
wieder sehr viele kommentare gelesen und
ein paar waren auch dabei warte mal 24
eine tiefe produkte das gibt es heute
von mir
ich wünsche euch dabei ganz viel spaß
und ja wir schauen jetzt mal was ich
alles so gekauft habe ich war schon
einkaufen müsste mit dem handy gefilmt
hier im haus
[Musik]
also leute ganz wichtig das wären als
youtuber wenn man so essens challenges
macht muss man immer am anfang schon das
thumbnail machen
bale weil sonst ist ja irgendwann das
essen hinweg deswegen ich wollte noch
mal schnell zeigen was sie alles so
gekauft haben hier eine gemüsepfanne
sommergarten okay die haben wir einfach
ganz normale erdbeer also tiefgefrorene
erdbeeren das hier sind aufbackbrötchen
neuen stück gelbe karotten mit
süßkartoffeln in rosmarin butter und die
pizza habe ich auch mal mitgenommen ich
meine gehört halt einfach dazu leute was
ihr aber auch auf jeden fall noch mal
loswerden wollte und zwar ich hoffe dass
das jetzt wieder offenbar kurz gesagt
mir geht es bei diesen 24 stunden
stellen ist in erster linie darum halt
möglichst viele sachen auszuprobieren
die ich sonst niemals wirklich probieren
würde meine tiefkühlpizza ist jeder mal
ich auch ja aber dieses tiefkühlgemüse
tiefkühl erdbeeren und so das habe ich
auch noch nie billig gegessen ich bin
auch wirklich der letzte mensch der sich
aufbackbrötchen hole dann gehe ich
lieber zum bäcker und mir da ein
vernünftiges brüchen ja deswegen bin ich
wirklich mal gespannt ist der erste hund
zweiter grund oder ihr werden wir doch
eher eine ziel ich bin jetzt du jemand
nicht achte mittlerweile schon auf meine
ernährung und ich versuche mich
natürlich auch möglichst gesund zu
ernähren
deswegen schaue ich auch bei jeder
challenge das ich ist vielleicht ein
bisschen gesünder hinkriege als man
jetzt ja sich erstmal so denkt weil es
gibt ja auch selber werde selber viele
ungesunde tiefkühlprodukte die habe ich
aber gar nicht gekauft deswegen weiß gar
nicht ob ich mir die fenster machen
werde
wir fangen jetzt erst mal mit der
gemüsepfanne da bin ich wirklich extrem
gespannt drauf schreibt gern mal die
kommentare auf ihr die schon mal
probiert habe das dann nach oben dafür
weitere channels und kommentiert auch
ideen für weitere talente in die
kommentare wie immer das gleiche und wir
sehen uns als in der küche und da ist
auch kartoffeln waren heute ich mache es
einfach mal in der falle ich glaube
ich habe allerdings schon von vielen
leuten gesagt dass das echt lecker sein
soll
gegen die habe ich jetzt gedacht dass
das hier kartoffeln sind aber das war
kein problem weil die habe ich ja auch
noch gekauft und wie bereitet man gleich
das ganze ist jetzt hier drin mit fünf
esslöffel wasser
ich würde sagen ich komme das jetzt mal
fertig und wir sehen ausgleich und falls
irgendwas falsch mache sei nicht böse
weil ich koche sehr selten so leute also
ich würde sagen sie schon mal gut aus
sollte jetzt jeden moment auch fertig
sein
haben wir nicht mal gespannt also leute
fertig irgendwie es ist ein bisschen
wenig also ich habe auf jeden fall die
ganze packung daran getan plus ein paar
kartoffeln und wir probieren das mal
möchte aber soweit ganz gut
und das wichtigste das ist für sie dafür
jetzt war vielleicht so eine soße aber
ich finde es eigentlich am drücker und
natürlich vor allem nicht teuer und das
wichtigste das ist gesund und ich war
eigentlich teuer so leute ich habe auch
vergessen aber ich wollte mich kurz was
dazu sagen weil es mir wirklich sehr gut
geschmeckt hat auch oder sowas und so
also keine ahnung ich glaube das mache
ich jetzt hier gemacht da es ging noch
extrem schnell und deshalb wie gesagt
sehr günstig probiert das sehr geehrt
immer auf was die gemüse mischungen oder
so fest dass ich würde sagen ich gehe
dann irgendwann später schlafen und
morgen probiere ich dann also ich kann
mich nicht daran erinnern ob ich schon
mal aufbackbrötchen jetzt nach bestimmt
irgendwann was mich auch ein bisschen
auf regen ist jetzt zwar noch die hälfte
drin der gemüseauflauf ist allerdings
von komplett weg hätte ich gar nicht
gedacht also muss ich vielleicht am
einkaufen morgen bis dann
guten morgen wir haben ganz schön früh
dieses scheiß dringen ist immer so laut
auf jeden fall habe ich bewusst und
jetzt mache ich mit frühstück wir ja
natürlich mit den aufbrüchen
dann würde ich mal die erdbahn probieren
mal gucken was das ist also wir müssen
da ich bin so dumm ich weiß nicht ob wir
das lesen können die tiefgefrorenen in
eine schüssel geben bei zimmertemperatur
zwei bis drei stunden auf trab
also ja ich habe einfach nur diese
aufbrüche aus gar kein problem haben wir
die zwei aufbackbrötchen die würde ich
erst mal rein und ich muss sagen die
sind eigentlich ja fast so groß wie
normale brötchen oder zumindest die
plättchen wenig halt kenne die sind aber
echt perfekte also brötchen und schon
mal fertig erdbeeren leider noch nicht
ganz bis man auch zwei stunden waren und
sind auch schön fluffig weiß man das so
gesagt
[Musik]
ach ich gern noch mal laufen
gefrühstückt habe ich jetzt zwei
herkömmlichen brötchen
ich musste ja sagen also ihrem
eigentlich schmeckt wie brötchen vom
bäcker so dabei ich mich im rat also
kann man auf jeden fall essen wobei ich
glaube so aufrecht hin zu kaufen ist
ziemlich normal wenn ich vielleicht auch
der einzige auf jeden fall muss ich
jetzt in die stadt
wir haben noch was wichtiges vor heute
und danach wollte ich noch mal zu einem
anderen supermarkt und schauen was die
so haben weil wenn ich das jetzt schon
mal mache muss ich mich ja auch
informieren und nicht nur bei einem
supermarkt kaufen deswegen würde ich
sagen wir fahren jetzt schon mal los ich
hab mich noch die pizza und die
erdbeeren der rest ist schon weg und das
mittagessen kommt ja noch und da
brauchen wir irgendwas ganz besonderes
deswegen bin ich mal gespannt was mich
wieder so finden sechseinhalb stunden
später in so leute hier kleines
placement für aldi ich muss sagen ich
bin eigentlich nie bei aldi deswegen bin
ich mal gespannt was die jetzt für mich
haben weil ich bin fürs mittagessen
natürlich was gesundes und möglichst
irgendwas was ich vor noch nie gegessen
habe deswegen bis gleich
[Musik]
war
ich bin schon wieder da das ist jetzt
das nervt mich jetzt irgend ein bisschen
weil die gab es viel viel mehr auswahl
als gestern in dem kaufhaus meines
vertrauens obwohl das eigentlich viel
größer ist wird ist jetzt vielleicht
nicht so das gesündeste also zumindest
das hier aber ich wollte das immer mal
probiert haben habe ich noch nie also
als tiefe variante sonst ganz gern immer
so wenn ich mal im skiurlaub hinunter so
schmeckt so was echt gut und zwar haben
wir so käser brief spitzen als okay sind
jetzt heute mal ein paar vom probieren
jetzt nicht alle besser dann hab ich mir
geholt bin ich mal gespannt
mini rollen also frühlingsrollen 20
stück ist ganz lustig weil ich letztens
noch frühlingsrollen probiert habe
schlechtes bewährtesten asiatischen
restaurant hier in köln falls ihr es
noch nicht gesehen habt check dass man
ab und hier laugenstangen zum aufbacken
ja also es drittel irgendwie immer mehr
so in die ungesunde richtung ab würde
ich mal sagen die sind wahrscheinlich
auch nicht gesund aber gut so ist das
der rest wäre langweilig gewesen also
das problem jetzt gleich mal ich bin
gespannt und wir fahren jetzt erst mal
nach hause
leute also das sind wirklich wieder so
leute ja das ist jetzt eine das
mittagessen
ich bin mal gespannt ich weiß nicht
vielleicht auch zu wenig keine ahnung es
irgendwie total schwer einzuschätzen es
sieht aber jetzt auf den ersten blick so
aus dass wir mit abstand das ungesunde
am ende werden wir mal die kalorien
zusammengerechnet leider war bei den
frühlingsrollen kein tipp dabei aber so
ist das
wir sehen uns vielleicht leute leute
okay und ich habe am anfang auch gesagt
mein ziel ist es möglichst gesund zu
leben na ja also es sieht ja ganz gut
aus eigentlich so sieht's aus diese käse
dinger sind leider ein bisschen
aufgeplatzt aber das kann man irgendwie
nicht vermeiden man muss die macht
perfekt genau lange drin lassen und die
habe ich jetzt wie gesagt und nicht so
gegessen noch früher ab und zu mal so
mozzarella sticks und freunde daran und
so naja diese laugenstangen sind extrem
aufgegangen auf jeden fall und die
führung freuen uns im auge nicht
schlecht aus ich will jetzt wirklich mal
gespannt
ich würde sagen wir fangen mit dem käse
gibt von mir heißen überhaupt keine
ahnung also den djp nation finde ich
jetzt nicht so gut aber es ist okay dann
schmeckt auf jeden fall dass es nicht so
gesund wie kommen wir zu den
frühlingsrollen die ich wirklich so noch
nie gegessen positiv geführt
ja probieren was man das ist nichts das
schmeckt wirklich alles andere als
asiatisch nach chinesischer art
hergestellt in dänemark aja chinesisch
ja auch wirklich nicht gut leute dass
ich nicht gut kann ich wirklich nicht
empfehlen
leute ich hab mal kurzem eine andere
kamera gewünscht ich frag mich
eigentlich wirklich wer sich sowas kauft
es schmeckt zwar ganz gut aber ich bin
mir ganz sicher so was ist extrem
ungesund ich hatte oftmals einen
laugenstangen oder laugenbrezel mit in
der schule
allerdings war die ihren frisch vom
bäcker also ich weiß wirklich nicht was
ich davon halten soll ein schmeckt okay
warum merkt die junge das ist aber egal
so leute ich habe schon angefangen das
video zu schneiden und ich habe auch
schon ein bisschen gerechnet
jedes mal kennt mittlerweile die erdmann
habe ich fast vergessen die sind ja als
aufgetan sollte
die man warte ich zeige dass ich mal
kurz auf die anderen gut ich will mich
da jetzt auch gar nicht beschweren ich
meine sind tiefgefroren
was willst du da erwarten aber wirklich
ausschauen wie erdbeeren dann tut das
jetzt nicht vom auch von dieser seite
die der aus wie das andere die
konsistente bisschen komisch ich vermute
mal dass damals e mails musik oder 1
gemacht wird was auch immer noch leute
kommen wir zu einem abschließenden fazit
erstmal muss ich sagen mir ist das jetzt
so durch das mittagsessen also ich will
mich wirklich nicht gut man fühlt sich
nicht ausgewogen ernährt sagen wir es
mal so und ich weiß ich also meine
tiefkühlpizza okay aber alles andere
halte ich für ziemlich sinnlos und nicht
wirklich näher haft zumindest für mich
keine ahnung da wollte ich mir was
frisches oder macht mir nudeln auch wenn
ich nicht so gut kommen können was man
aber sagen muss es ist natürlich extrem
günstig habe es mal ausgerechnet ich
habe insgesamt für alle sachen 15 eur 2
bezahlen also alle sachen die ich im
video gezeigt habe davon habe ich die
tiefkühlpizza ich war welche gegessen
die erdbeeren auch nicht also ohne spaß
das kann man auch nicht wirklich alles
und ich würd mal sagen ein bisschen
aufgeholt kann man maximal auf zehn euro
für 24 stunden ist zwar an sich okay was
ich dann aber wirklich überraschend fand
da hätte ich gedacht dass das meer ist
die kalorien
wir sind bei 1421 kalorien ungefähr plus
minus 200 würde ich mal schätzen das
kann ich ja nie genau sagen so weit ich
weiß benötige ich pro tag ungefähr 2200
also zu wenig zumal man ja auch sagen
muss diese käse cracker oder wie auch
immer die teil heißen schreibt gerne
meine kommentare die haben alle schon
450 gut so ist dass das war's mit
in diesem video ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen lassen wir sehr gerne daumen
nach oben da und schreibt in die
kommentare was ihr nächste woche sehen
wollt dann bin ich mal gespannt
es macht immer wieder spaß und ja das
war es von mir haut rein